جهاز الاخبار من الجزيره لما كنتم السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله قال مراسل الجزيره ان
مقاتلات اسرائيليه استهدفت بعدد من
الصواريخ موقعين للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في
مخيم المغازي وستقطع غزه وجنوبي القطاع
واضاف مراسلون ان غاره الاسرائيليه
الثالثه استهدفت محيطا مرصد للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه شرق بيت حانون شماليه القطاع
بشرا الى ان الغارات الاسرائيليه الحقت
اضرار الماديه في هذه المواقع وفي المنازل
المجاوره وقالت كتائب القسام ما التابعه
لحركه حماسنا دفاعتها الجويه تصدت لطائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه بصواريخ
ارض جو بالمضادات الارضيه
وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الطائراته
الحربيه اغارت على موقع عسكريا تحت الارض
يستخدموا لتصنيع قبائل فصاروخيه في منطقه
المغازي وسطى قطع غيار غزه واقل جيش
الاحتلال انه رصد اطلاقه ست قذائف صاروخيه
باتجاه اسرائيل
سقطت احداها داخل قطع غزه واخرى في منطقه
مفتوحه داخل اسرائيل بينما اعترضت القبه
الحديديه اربعه قذائف وحمل بيان الجيش
الاسرائيلي حركه حماس المسؤوليه عن كل ما
يحدث في قطاع غزه متواعدنا اياها بدفعه
ثمن اي خروقات تستهدف اسرائيل بحسب تعبيره
قالت حركه حماس ان التصدي هي كتائب القسام
للعدوان الاسرائيلي بالصواريخ المضاده
للطيرات اربك جيش الاحتلال ومستوطنيه وعند
المقاومه تواصل القيامه بواجبها بالدفاع
عن الشعب الفلسطيني وستبقى درعه وسيفه من
جانبها قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي عند
المقاومه لن تتردد في اتخاذ قرار المواجهه
وانها لن تفرق بالدم الفلسطيني في جنين
والقدس
ياتي اطلاق الصواريخ من غزه عقب العمليه
العسكريه التي جنتها قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي امسي داخل مدينه جنين بالضفه
الغربيه واسفلت وفقه وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه عن استشهاد تسعه فلسطينيين هذا
هو اكد المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
نبيله بردينا ان التعاون الامنيه مع
اسرائيل لم يعد قائما وقال ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه ستتوجه للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لاضافه ملف مجزره جنين الى
الملفات السابقه
اعلنت وزيره الدفاع الكنديه انيتا اننا
بلادها ستزود اوكرانيا باربع دبابات من
برازيلي بارت 2 خلال الاسابيع القادمه
واضافت الوزيره الكنديه ان هذه الدبابات
جاهزه للقتال وسيتم تدريب الجنود
الاوكرانيين على كيفيه استخدامها ياتي هذا
الاعلان بعد يوم من اعلان كل من الولايات
المتحده والمانيا عن ارسال الدبابات
قتاليه الى اوكرانيا
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز لما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير